i loved hannibal
i am super super super happy i get to
talk to you guys today
but before we get started um i just have
to start with uh hugh um
please say to your better half uh how
much i enjoyed uh homeland
and um i watched every episode and uh
you were great in the last season
i just wanna for people that have never
seen homeland they should absolutely
watch it
yes those three people should get on the
tv now and so what
so uh every time i talk to people i try
to ask some fun questions to break it up
a little bit so we're going to start
with those
what foods are you guys cooking in the
quarantine
i mean i'm cooking the same foods i was
cooking before just a lot
a lot more frequently i i don't think
i've uh
i've done anything radical and and
mostly it's defined by
what my eldest son
will or will not eat are you making
anything um
i have discovered delivery artisanal
mushrooms
so i've been garlicking and buttering
mushrooms and putting them on pasta and
toast
and things like that and they're not
psychedelic although i have dabbled
uh not effectively because i always
overdo it and regret it
with the artisanal mushrooms they're
just right
um so uh for hugh what tv show
would you love to guest star on and for
brian what tv show would you love to
guest
write and direct we are currently
working our way through um i may destroy
you
uh which i've found to be pretty
remarkable
um and on on pretty much every level
she's incredible
and the show is is wonderful so there
you go that's my obsession right now
i would love to write and direct
anything
with phoebe waller bridge just because i
think she is so spectacularly talented
and she would raise the level of my own
writing
um but let's face it
uh also i think she'd be able to add um
uh dialogue uh to whatever she's doing
you know tweak things oh yes yes elevate
i'll
elevate the work completely do you guys
have a favorite ride at disneyland
i've only been to disneyland uh once
which was last year i like the cars ride
i i love haunted mansion i i'm a big fan
of haunted mansion i do enjoy the new
star wars rides quite a bit
they're a lot of fun um but haunted
mansion is tried and true
and um i'm very excited for the revamp
of splash mountain absolutely
because i i previously could not
proclaim my love for splash mountain
because of its problematic subject
matter but now i will be able to
that they're going to be shifting that
into
a a more modern story what movie do you
guys think you've seen the most
realistically it would be something from
my youth you know just that the
the feels like there's about seven
movies on british tv that were on a loop
from 1970 to 1990
like mary poppins and the bond movies
but uh like kind of with
of of my own volition maybe it might
actually be something like
like bringing up baby i went through a
period yeah i
i love that movie and i've watched it
several times off the top of my head
kerry grant's the best pretty remarkable
yeah
i mean catherine had been on him in that
movie uh howard hawk
uh i mean that's a fantastic movie yeah
it's kind of perfect in its own way
um gosh there are so many uh the shining
is probably one of them
uh alien uh
a lot of spy who loved me was probably
something that i saw more than anything
else
in my childhood including star wars okay
do you remember your first movie or tv
show crush
i do not i mean probably mary poppins
but for the same reason but uh
no i know i actually don't have i don't
remember my first crush
brian wasn't necessarily in a movie but
i remember being
very captivated by pete townsend's nose
i found it architecturally
brilliant and uh i was aware of my
eyeballs feeling good staring at him
got it um jumping into why i get to talk
to you guys today
uh i think the first thing that i'm very
curious about is do you know
if the series is doing well on netflix
has anyone told you
no one officially has reached out i've
had people online say like oh my god
look uh hannibal's trending on netflix
i'm like what does that
mean exactly like does that mean people
have watched two minutes of it
like you know there's like the
algorithms are kind of funny on netflix
where if you watch two minutes of
something then it goes into the
viewership
uh so i hope people are watching more
than two minutes and i'm glad i
i i don't i don't know but two minutes
is all we need from you guys
they could just tune in for those two
minutes that would be i get it i'm out
oh he's a cannibal
it rhymes i think that um it'd probably
be different if you had if we had made
the show
for netflix right i mean um perhaps you
get more information back that way
but you were you were surprised on our
little reunion video that that was the
first time that you had heard that it
was
uh that somebody had said like oh it's
trending on netflix and you're like is
it
right and i was it was my face learning
about that i learned that in the moment
yeah when you told me um but but like
you i
also didn't know what it meant i'm glad
it's finding that audience it's so
interesting because we
we didn't necessarily make it with a
network in mind we were just trying to
be as
authentic as we knew how to the source
material
so it's it's always interesting when you
do a show
on a network and then you're trying to
like get another season out of a
different network and
the take is always like well that's nbc
show and why would we want to take nbc's
sloppy seconds for
you know whatever reason so it is
fascinating that now that it is on
netflix
and people are discovering it for the
first time
i guess it it it illustrates the
efficacy
of our marketing campaigns when we were
on air
i mean it also illustrates the fact that
that not only
like you brian and us but nbc also kind
of
allowed us to make a show that wasn't
overtly
obviously an nbc show yeah believe me
i'm getting into that
uh i guess
that's fine yeah no i have questions but
so i think one of the things that i'm
very curious about
and i think fans are curious about is
who actually owns
the rights to hannibal right now in
terms of if you guys
magically could get money together to do
more who
needs to say yes who needs to sign off
martha delaurentis is
is it controls the rights for
the hannibal character and galmont who
produced
the hannibal television series that we
worked on
uh has the rights to those characters
and those situations so if we want to
continue
telling the tales that we were telling
gaumont needs to be involved and martha
delaurentis needs to be involved
and then of course we need a network to
want to
to platform us who owns uh silence the
lambs
science of the lambs is owned by mgm and
so what what happened early on and why
there was sort of like kind of a
sticking point
for us with the the the clarisse writes
is that
mgm was originally working on a deal
with martha delaurentis that had
everything in
one like package and
then galmont came along and offered
martha a significantly
you know greater deal that mgm couldn't
match
and so there's been a little bit of
animosity between the studios because
mgm's like hey you were gonna do it with
us and she was like yeah but you didn't
give me the better deal and they were
kind of upset about that so that's why
it's been sort of like a sticking point
to try to get
the clarisse rights because they were
like why would we help you
when you like they're basically bill
pullman
and sleepless in seattle
good analogy uh i listen i put on
twitter that i was going to talk to you
guys
and rather than go through the 500
versions of this
uh my one blanket question is is there
any sort of
update in terms of doing anything more
with you guys together with hannibal
um is it just one of these things that
we're just hope or just should be up
you know what i mean like can you share
anything and i think that sums up about
a thousand questions
i wish there was something that that was
definitive we've you know i've had
conversations with hugh
and maz and other members of the cast in
terms of like
well this is what we would do if we were
allowed to come back
and there's some you know ideas that i'm
very excited about
and things that that sort of continue
the strange trajectory
of season three but i i have not been
approached even though
like i've i've knocked on every door uh
and rang every bell and martha and i you
know
every every couple of years pick up our
our
uh bags and and go door-to-door and
see if anybody's interested in
revisiting and really like the biggest
hurdle is that
we were somebody else's show and so what
i love about
like netflix uh platforming the show now
is that there's an opportunity for it to
be seen as a netflix show and maybe that
will recon
uh figure their appetite
so to speak but it's nobody has said
anything to me
officially and believe me
like you know the nickel hooker on uh
you know the red light district i am
hanging out the window
waving my legs uh so they know i'm ready
if netflix came to you and said we would
love to do like a two-hour movie
rather than another season is that
something that interests you or do you
think that the
price of doing a movie would almost be
like we should just do another season
i'd love to hear hugh's take on this
i just want to work with you again so
i would do whatever anybody offered me
in whatever capacity
i agree with brian and and i would defer
to brian's
sense of what what would work you know
if
the story that that that he wanted to
tell and where he imagined taking it
could work in that format i mean
obviously this is a
wildly hypothetical question but um
but yeah in in in in the hypothetical
absolutely
i mean i'm in basically there was
recently a great ds9 doc that came out
what we left behind
right and some fans were asking if you
guys uh have
thought about doing some sort of behind
the scenes dock on the making of
hannibal
you know interviews with people um you
know sharing stuff that maybe has never
been seen has that come up at all
there was a the book that came out um
i think even maybe a couple of books and
there was obviously
scott thompson's kind of behind the
scenes i forget what it was called now
do you remember brian
um there was an innuendo
that was almost certainly an innuendo
which he did at the time and we'd kind
of come in on the weekends and and
um and drink whiskey and answer scott's
um
impertinent questions but beyond that no
i don't think so jumping into the actual
behind-the-scenes nitty-gritty of the
making of the show
um talk a little bit about ryan when did
you realize hugh was the right person
for the role because i believe you were
the first one cast he was
um basically when we sat down
and they they're with these things
there's always a list
and the list comes from the network of
people like who they're excited about
and they'll say like here's here here's
a list of people that were excited about
and i was like you nancy
and then i was like let's get a meeting
and it was very it was very uh
simple and clear like actually the
casting on this
was clear in terms of usually
you're waiting for the person to come
into the room and then basically
announce themselves as the character
in a way that snaps into a cohesive
vision as you understand it
for the role and with this it was like
oh i
absolutely see how
he could be the guy let's let's go have
a meeting with him and we
did in new york and um
that that yummy breakfast restaurant
that's next to
the the burger joint um and the
is it is it the mandaria like what's the
name of that hotel
i forget but you're right it was in the
hotel that's that's all i mean i
remember lots more about the meeting but
not about the location are you talking
about the burger place that's in the
lobby of that midtown hotel
yes and right across from that is a
great little breakfast joint and that's
where we went
and i remember like hugh it was very it
was it was fascinating because i hadn't
met hugh
and we really didn't sort of like
connect as human beings until we just
like went
to dinner just the two of us
and then it was like oh we're gonna be
friends um
but that was like what was so
interesting about hugh is that you were
very guarded
you were very like okay who are all
these people at the table looking at me
like i'm a meal
and like what exactly do they want for
me
and that's like the perfect
right like a meal is is prime
qualification for this job yes
i felt like it wasn't your first time at
the rodeo and that
you were uh when you were asking
questions you were
half expecting nobody to have answers to
them
it was my impression that's well you
know i think
so what i remember is um i was
i was in europe i was doing a play at
the time and so we you know we met
anyway we met venus infer and with your
future wife on hannibal
uh that's right exactly with that with
nina ariander
and um brian anyway so came and met
brian
um and martha lady o'connell pt
o'connell there but was my quite yeah
katie was there too
it was from goman at the time um and i'd
read the
the the pilot um but
beyond that didn't have a sense of where
it was going so yes my questions were
were you know how do you imagine this
proceeding and actually
i mean in some respects obviously i've
you know had a lot of meetings i guess
one way or the other but but it kind of
was my first time at the rodeo in terms
of
i think sitting down with somebody at
that stage of a project of a tv project
um
you know as the things being put
together
and anybody who knows brian will know
that if you ask the question
so do you have any sense of how this
might develop you're really opening a
big door
and so and brian said well you know
funny you should ask you know
his five seasons of tv in my in my mind
essentially and that's what we talked
about we talked a little bit about the
about will um as somebody
who may or may not be on the spectrum in
some capacity and
and and i knew a little bit about that
and i was curious
um but really i was amazed to hear the
the depth of his his you know his vision
for where we might go
um and then we met we went out
for cocktails after the theater a couple
of weeks later and then it was a whole
different thing and then as brian said
we kind of became friends we laughed and
laughed and laughed
um one of the things about you being the
first person cast is that
obviously you have to play or i'm sure
they asked you to play against
other people to figure out who they
wanted to cast or did you not have to do
that
there were a couple of episodes of that
but but
one of which was uh with mass
um really because we all knew
pretty much simultaneously and almost
from the get-go that that was
the the obviously the best possible
um not i'm gonna say root and like if
that were to if that were to work out as
it did
it would be the best possible thing so
so that happened
i think mostly i would say to persuade
the people i had to sign off on it
none of the people that i just mentioned
and obviously not us here
that it was a good idea unfortunately
they they saw the light
when you guys read for the first time um
did you realize oh this uh this needs to
happen right i had worked with maz
uh i don't know 10 years previously or
something on king arthur which is a
completely couldn't have been a more
different experience we were all in
dublin and
wearing armor and riding horses for
months on end and drinking guinness and
having a great time and getting to know
each other and we
we had kind of stayed in touch you know
we'd seen each other once or twice since
then
um when we when he when we
then met and did this reading he came to
the play
the night before um as did david slade
who was there for the was going to be
there the next day so they came to the
play
they came up to my dressing room
afterwards um
and we sat around we talked about you
know the stuff we were gonna do the next
day
and the scenes like i didn't need
persuading i already was
fully fully like i packed my bags i was
on the boat i was you know i was gone
as far as mads was concerned it was
obviously the best idea
um but but then
in just in that conversation and we kind
of continued the conversation
the next day when we were recording
something because
because that because how can i put it
um as far as i was concerned it felt
like we were already making the show
together
so mads's take on it and his his angle
and his
his kind of granular approach to it was
just was was
as exciting as when i first met brian
and he taught me through what he
what he wanted to make let's talk about
the first season he's constantly dealing
with like he's in decline he's stressed
out
i'm curious as an actor playing a role
like that
um are you able to leave what you're
doing on set
or does something like that do you sort
of take home a bit of the character at
night
to sort of because you want to because
you want to stay in that mental state so
you can
just flip it back on the next day no i
i have no trouble um going home
really i like it and um i
my first uh the first of our two sons
was born
uh almost exactly halfway through the
first season um i mean we
actually during a kind of hiatus we took
over the
over the holidays which was kind of
extended a bit
thank god and we returned to toronto to
film the last six episodes with a
newborn so i mean like i was not going
home you know
i was going home to to provide moral
support because i'd been
away all day and um enter nurse
and of course of course to nurse because
apparently and i can
tell you now it is possible
but but and also it's true that every
single line of this
essentially of this show went through
brian and came
came from brian was filtered through
brian of course there was a writer's
room
um and but but
you know it was all being he was a real
i think this is fair to say brian right
he was re
not reimagining it but but working on it
all the time and elevating it honestly
um every single time we would have a
conversation or just that a new version
of a scene or an episode would arrive
and it was
enriched and and elevated um and so
really i was going home to start working
on what was happening the next day i
didn't have time to
stop and kind of live in what i just
done because it was uh
it was fully consuming you get the green
light you're gonna make the show
how much did everyone realize about the
level of
gore and what you wanted to put on
screen um
early on and how much was it they were
seeing dailies
and being like wait what we made friends
with standards and practices very
quickly
just because we i understood
fundamentally that that this person was
going to be
the arbiter of what gets on screen and
what doesn't get on screen
so we had very frank conversations about
this is what we're trying to achieve we
know there are parameters to broadcast
television
and how can you help us slip through
whatever you know narrow uh
openings we could we could access and
they were incredibly
helpful because you know when we wanted
to have somebody cut off their face and
feed it to the dogs like well this isn't
the book and it kind of has to happen so
how do we do that
and they said you know bury it in shadow
and make the blood black
and you're gonna get away with a lot
more and there was
rarely any instances where they were
like
i don't think there's a way for you to
pull that off there was one where
somebody got disemboweled by a ceiling
fan
and uh that they were like i just don't
see
how you can pull that off on
and and you know not show red blood
and keep that in shadow and
and also ultimately it was too expensive
of a gag
so i let it go but i was like there's a
way there's we can do it like
like there's a way to disembowel
somebody with a ceiling fan i know it
um but it was it was really just being
kind of professional
and direct with the standards and
practices people and making them our
allies as opposed to our enemies because
they they have their jobs and they're
not malicious
and they do want to tell good stories
and
uh you know they were they were
incredibly helpful
um one of the things uh that i love like
anyone who's watched the show is the
visual style of hannibal
can you talk about how early on you guys
knew what you wanted it to be how much
did david slade
contribute early on into the look of the
show
i think the elegance of of the aesthetic
is is very much you know in our very
first meetings with with david slade we
sat down and we did talk about
elegance and horror and there was only
one differentiation where we sort of
didn't necessarily agree
or we weren't speaking the same language
and on the subject matter which was how
to portray the violence and david was
very
very much of the mind that he didn't
want to romanticize the violence he
didn't want the violence to become
sensationalized in any way or because he
thought violence should be ugly and
unbearable and hard to look at and we
shouldn't uh
glorify it in any way to make it easier
to digest for the audience
and i was like oh yeah no like we're
gonna like it's gonna be gorgeous and
weird
like we're like we'll be fine but it
like i felt like we were speaking
the same like his version of violence
was different than my version of
violence and david and i are very sort
of
different people kind of just
fundamentally
but i can see how i can say blue
and he can say aqua and we're talking
about the same color
uh one of the things is you obviously
have different directors helming
different episodes
um hugh can you talk about what it was
like working with the different
directors and
um how much did the individual directors
have the ability to sort of insert what
they wanted
while still maintaining the overall
vision
of what brian of what you wanted for the
series
that's uh that's a good series of
questions
um um i suppose it was the first time
i'd worked uh on a sustained time
on a tv show and so with us you know
with a series of directors and obviously
in within that you get some directors
that
that return um and what i learned kind
of broadly
was that this isn't quite what you asked
but i suppose what i learned is that
um i think that that there are three
primary qualities um for director
one is working with actors one is we're
working with a camera and one is having
a
kind of broader understanding of of
story and
and the shape of the thing and most
directors are really good at two
and every so often you get somebody who
comes in who's
really really can man do all three and
that's remarkable and
not entirely necessary but great you
know wonderful when it happens
and i felt like we had we had a really
strong
uh crew of directors if that's a if
that's a phrase
um and and i mean
i don't you know i don't know what
happens before they arrive on set i'm
not really privy
to that in terms of the bible in terms
of you know brian saying this is how we
shoot this is not how we shoot
david obviously also having established
that and jim hawkinson the dp
who you know has an incredibly specific
look that he created
which took a lot of time so that that in
itself would limit
just his the parameters of the way he
was lighting would limit what you know
what how what and how you would shoot
right well i think it's interesting
you're bringing up uh
uh david and jim hawkins as a team
creating the the aesthetic that we
essentially
you know extrapolated from and embraced
for the rest of the series because it
does look like the pilot and it does
you yes we go to different locations and
are telling different kinds of stories
but it all has those rich savory
colors that are you know
en entrouted with darkness
and in beautiful ways so
for me when talking to directors that
were coming into the show
it was really about trying to to give
them a sense of support that that
this isn't going to be your standard
television experience this isn't going
to be
uh there won't be expectations of
standardized coverage and dirty overs
and things like that there are
there are things that we we love on this
show
that are much more classic in terms of
the filmmaking
you're not so much handheld unless
there's a moment that
really merits holding the camera and
letting it vibrate with the character's
experience
but most of the time it was very it was
about
really elegant filmmaking and
i think a lot of folks who came to the
show
were just relieved when i said you're
making a pretentious art film
and so all of those things that you want
to show off
for on a standard television procedural
can never do
this is your place where you can pull
them off so let's hear
what you want to do so really was
a yes and environment and from you know
i took groundlings classes in my early
20s and the thing that i learned most
about this
i actually probably learned more about
storytelling and character development
from the groundlings than
any other writing class i'd ever taken
because it was always about character
specificity
and it was always about you know
sticking to your guns and strong choices
and
most importantly it was a yes and
dynamic
and i feel like on our show what we all
really tried to craft was a yes and
dynamic
so if hugh and mas are coming to me with
an idea
my response is yes and let's do this as
opposed to
no but like why would we do that
because it's just like it's a shitty way
to interact it's a shitty way to
support a troop and i think anytime
i do a show i i love to
create an environment where everybody
feels like they have a voice
and what they're doing and you know
a it's i can always blame somebody else
it's like well that was hugh's idea
like so if you didn't like it that's on
him um
but b it's just it's
you know i i'm not so arrogant that i
know that i have all the best ideas and
i have enough experience working with
people like you and maz
who come and say
this is what i've been thinking and i go
like oh my god you just solved all these
problems for me i'm gonna take your
ideas and put them down on paper and
thank you very much
and i from what i understand that's not
always the case because
uh you know people are functioning at
different
uh levels of security and
because it's an adaptation of a work
we're all
interpreting it we're all interpreting
what thomas harris put down
so my interpretation is no more valid
than maz's interpretation or hughes
interpretation
uh or david's interpretation so we have
to figure out a way
where we're all contributing and we all
feel like we have ownership
and it's just a it's just a happier
place if we do that
my memory of it is the same as brian's
that my sense from other directors and
maybe they wouldn't
necessarily say this although some of
them did but but you know out of a sense
of tact or something was that they were
just thrilled
really to be there because the the
parameters for what they could do and
what they could play with
were were broad even you know even on
this kind of network
show um they there was there was room
for them to really
do some interesting and technical stuff
i think i mean particularly in the
crime scenes murder scenes whatever so
that was um
it was kind of nice to be with people
when they're when they're really
feeling their oats and
in terms of collaboration um
brian i i think matt both mads and i had
the experience
of sitting i remember sitting with mads
in
in the hannibal's office one day we were
looking at a scene we're about to do
imagine's looking at it and he said yeah
this line here
i actually included that in an email to
brian just because i was
like he said i was trying to just kind
of i just wanted to kind of
judge up my email a bit basically like
like kind of make it a bit more exciting
and brian put it in the script
and we both had that experience of an in
the in the effort
to to illustrate what the hell was going
through our minds at any given time you
know
trying to put it into into words and
brian in the best possible way
and it's an incredibly flattering thing
right saying oh i'll have that
i remember actually i remember early on
like maybe even i think it was maybe
when we were filming the the first
episode having a drink
in my trailer with brian and lawrence
and we're having a whiskey
and um and i had a i mean
this would not be the norm but i think i
had a book of poetry or something
and we got talking about that and i said
in the kind of way you do after a long
day and you've had a whiskey or
something we're talking about words and
i said oh you know
i like words they're they're pack
animals right they they work well
together
no i said and then brian
it's like seven months later it
re-emerges in the line but but he's
turned it into pat hunter's
right i remember that really clearly oh
i think i think
i said that and he's improved it it was
just
it was the best it was the best it's a
well
it's it's fun when that happens because
you know
working with madison they're both really
smart
gentlemen and they know how to turn a
phrase
so i'm not i'm i'm not going gonna walk
past that berry hanging on the bush and
not pick it
one of the reasons the show is so well
is that it was never forced to do
22 episodes you had 13 episodes
um and was it always designed like
how did the 13 episode number come about
was it ever discussed doing 10 episodes
or was it
well there's a financial model to 13
episodes that the studio understands in
terms
of its uh you know because
traditionally it's like 22 24 26
episodes depending on like when i was
first do
started doing television there was a
season of voyager where we did 26
episodes and it was
murder for everybody um
so there's there are financial models
for all of this stuff
and and i think the the most effective
financial model for us
was one of 13 episodes at a certain
price point
and so it was kind of you know embraced
by
the line producers and the the studio in
terms of having
a a model that worked best
unlike most series that aired on tv
on network tv um usually if they make a
pilot they watch the pilot gets put on
you know they vote uh i believe hannibal
was just picked up with no pilot
am i mistaken no it's direct to series
right so
what listen they obviously greenlit is
based on your pilot script
uh but they don't really know what
they're getting until they start seeing
the visuals
that you're filming so i'm very curious
what was it like when you started
turning in dailies or when they started
seeing rough cuts
in terms of what you wanted to put on
the air and you sort of talk about you
know the reaction from executives
and you know did you ever get any
feedback that this is too far
were they sort of immediately embracing
the style you were going for
well it's interesting because we
with the show there was
there was you know i don't know if you
remember
much of this hue but there was there was
a casting kerfuffle
on who to cast for hannibal lecter and
there was
a a difference of opinion on
what a a television network a
traditional television network would
want as a leading man and what
we would want as uh
an actor playing hannibal lecter um
to personify that character and i think
the network wanted somebody that was
much more poppy much more mainstream
uh much more american i think
in in some ways and uh
but that was just them thinking about
like okay how do we get the biggest
audience for our television show
we have to cast john cusack as hannibal
lecter and everybody will tune in
because won't that be surprising
that was my face and i was like
well let's go ahead make an offer um
so there was there was there was some
resistance to mass mickelson because he
was european
because he was somebody
that you could look at and say like yeah
i buy that he eats people
and you know that there was an
interesting kind of
we were dealing with a deaf a very
american
uh network that wanted a very american
actor to sell to american audiences
and i and all the creatives on the show
wanted somebody who was the the best
person for the role and
because we didn't have that that kind of
uh john cusack hugh grant
um these are some of the names that the
network really wanted
uh in the role that felt like it was
more about selling the movie than
making the most authentic movie and
that's not to say that neither of those
things are invalid
uh but because we cast mass and because
it was sort of a
uh it was an interesting dance because i
would say maz mickelson that said no how
about
hugh grant i'm like great make an offer
he's going to say no he would make an
offer he'd say no and they'd be like
what about maz nicholson they're like
well how about john cusack and like
great make an offer he's going to say no
they'd make an offer he'd say no and say
what about as mickelson
and that was like that carousel went
around for i think three or four months
after we had cast hue
it like it was going on for a while um
and finally i just said like
maz is the guy that's the guy that i see
in the role
and i have to write it and i have to
champion it i have to understand it
and and jennifer sulky at nbc
bless her heart was like okay like
that's your guy
and i believe you and i trust you and
i'm excited about the vision for the
show
but for the other sort of marketing
folks they were like oh this show isn't
going to break through for us they sort
of
gave up on it a little bit because we
were casting
a european guy
as the face of that they wanted to be
much more
accessible uh and i felt that they were
they were right for their reasons but
wrong for my reasons
and so the gift of that the gift of
casting mass mickelson is that their
investment in the show
uh became dramatically decreased and so
that allowed us to do a lot of things
that we wouldn't have been able to do
if they were saying like no this show
needs to get 10 million people watching
it every
every every week because then we would
have to
really be tied down to certain
parameters of storytelling that we're
going to
mesh with a mainstream audience
so maz was the gift that allowed us
to tell the story the way that we wanted
to tell it because
the network was like well it's not the
person that we wanted and we don't
really see him in this role
and we were like fine just let us make
the show and they were like here and so
you know we didn't get great ratings and
we didn't get great numbers and the
network was
was behind us but they weren't as behind
us as they would have been
if we had cast who they wanted
um but i think in the grand universal
scheme it was the best thing for the
show
a because we got to have mass and human
scenes together and they were electric
and also we got to do things that were
questionable with the content because
they we didn't we didn't we weren't we
were no longer
expected to achieve a certain goal i
think that if you would cast
someone like cusack let's arbitrarily
throw that name out there
um they might have insisted more on a
procedural
show and less serialized storytelling
they would have insisted on all sorts of
things we wouldn't have got it in a away
with a third of the things that we got
away with
or you know tried to do in our
narratives
just because you know low expectations
are good
you know low expectations will allow
artists to flourish in ways
that when there are higher expectations
and
you know more restrictions because
there's more writing on it for the
network
and that's why they cast james spader
and the blacklist because that they were
like see this is what we wanted to do
that you wouldn't do
and so we're going to do it this is our
show you go do your little show
we'll air it but this is the show that
we really wanted to do
and the moment they cast james spader
and
the blacklist was when they kind of took
their attention away
from what we were doing on hannibal so
it was really about like
oh let them do their weird little show
like we're not paying very much for it
and we're going to bury it on a
thursday night at 10 or a friday night
at 10 and
so we only need it to perform this much
and
we performed this match
[Laughter]
but right and then we became i suppose a
show that that
meant something different to them in
terms of value because we got good
reviews and because
we we stuck out in a different way in
their roster of shows right and that
that's also a good look and i think it's
something that they were actively
interested in in pursuing right and and
so we fit it into a different part of
the model which was exactly
i think where we want it to be yes like
i think it's where we where it's where
the universe definitely
placed us so we could maximize what we
wanted to do
the other thing though is in 10 years
people are still going to be talking
about your show
and what you guys pulled off um in terms
of the quality the writing the acting
all i mean everything about the series
it's going to be remembered
so i think that um no matter what
you know the whatever happened it's
going to be one of those shows
you know just anyway um for each of you
what is something that you got away with
that you still
can't believe there's just so there's so
many i mean this
there's so many literally the first
thing that comes to mind is
is like remembering that like doing a
shot where i had to kneel it was when i
was
as where will was was imagining
having been in eddie izzard's shoes
as it were when he kills the nurse to
escape and he
puts her eyes out and i'm like well what
would it what kind of face would you
pull while you're
you know popping someone's eyeballs out
with your thumb and you know
maybe i'll smile she's like what the
hell
i'm just getting covered with more i
learned more about
blood movie blood tv blood whatever fake
blood
every every department has its own blood
and i have been covered in all of them
i've been like
the makeup department has theirs and the
wardrobe department has theirs and the
special effects department has theirs
and we'd stand around and have these
conferences because they're designed for
like a you know delicate spattering or
like you know
not a full shower and i don't know it
was
i didn't think i realized at the time
how unlikely it was
to be so regularly engulfed in blood
and it was great it did it was it was
fascinating the
uh
i'm trying to think of not necessarily
the resistance the
um
i'm blanking um
we developed a relatively thick skin for
what we could get away with
and to the point that
we were getting away with things and we
had no idea how extreme it was that we
were getting away
with and i watched the other night
um the mason verger scene where he's
cutting off his face and feeding it to
the dogs
because i was looking i was looking for
ellen muth's death to answer
like somebody's question because they
they
uh had a picture on facebook of somebody
inside a flaming room
and i was like we did that and i was
looking for that to send that picture
but then stumbled upon upon the mason
verger scene
and then i watched it and i was laughing
and i was like
this is [ __ ] ghoulish
and uh just the the
whimsy at which hugh and maz were
playing the scene and the the
the straight kind of take on
on the material which was so outlandish
um and michael pitt was so bizarre and
cackling
that like i'm curious just to show that
scene to people
out of context because it's so bizarre
so
violent and yet kind of oddly funny
and after i watched i was like i'm
really proud that we pulled that off
because
everybody's great in the scene and
it's funny but it's super twisted
and i just like it was it was a it was a
nice moment where
like i rarely look back at my own work
and that was a case where i was like
oh because you know you're in so many
different head spaces and you have so
many
different things flying at your head
that that when you actually do it and
when it errors
you're sort of on to the next thing and
to stop and sort of go like
wow we did an exceptionally perverse
scene
that i hadn't seen before and everybody
was great in it and it was well
filmed i was just proud i was proud of
the show and i was proud of everybody in
it
and it made me laugh because i was just
like oh geez like
how high was i when i was writing that
uh how long did you have what was your
shooting schedule
on the series how many days did you have
to film
was it seven days an episode seven
we turned over episodes every eight days
but usually had two days of second unit
right so you had an eight day shooting
schedule two days of second unit
yeah eight plus two ten got it because i
was gonna say one of the things i think
a lot of people don't realize is the
importance of second unit
on a series like this getting insert
shots getting
other things can you sort of mention
because they're they're almost unsung
heroes
it's there's so much of it like you know
i i sing chris burns praises
uh daily it feels and he
was our our uh our second unit director
and director and directed a lot of
scenes and a lot of inserts and every
every beautiful shot of blood spray
or weaponry is chris byrne
and uh he was vital to the aesthetic of
the show
he amplified the the production value
for us and what's what i find so
interesting
is that say for instance the scene at
the end
of season three when we go out to a
location and we're shooting
this big fight sequence between uh
mazz and hugh and richard
and but we're at a location so we're
we're never going to get everything and
we're only going to be able to get those
wides
and then chris will go to the stage take
a photograph
of the location blow it up in the
background
throw it out of focus and get all of
these
wonderful close-ups so most of that
finale
uh all the shots of of hugh and mass
sort of looking at each other looking at
weapons
charging that's all in a little room
on a stage not even on the like the
proper stage part but like sort of in a
little anterior room
and it's all really close up very
surgical
work and we wouldn't be able to pull it
off and
if we didn't have somebody like chris
byrne being able to direct it
and actors who can actually
transport themselves from one
sequence of filming to another sequence
of filming and make it feel
seamless so that that takes a lot of
people knowing what they're doing
yeah i rewatched the series three finale
yesterday to get ready for this it's one
of the things i watched and i would not
have been able to tell i just watched it
yesterday i had no idea
that you pull what you did in that scene
yeah it's it's but every episode has
has an example of that and really it's i
mean what's so interesting now i find
in 4k as we are we are
uh um looking at things through
a much sharper lens than we
were before at a standard 2k
and when i saw the shining recently in a
4k projection
one of the things about higher
resolution is that you can tell the
inauthenticity of a performance
very quickly in 4k more so than 2k you
can
like watching the shiny in 4k i saw
maybe a half a dozen times where jack
nicholson totally broke character
lost his focus and then you know drifted
and then snapped back into focus in the
scene
in a way that shelly duvall never broke
character
and was completely 100 percent
encountered she was terrorized
but what i took away from that
experience
is that the more vivid that we get with
our resolutions
the more authentic actors have to be
because at 4k
you can see [ __ ] that you didn't
smell in 2k and
all of this is to say whenever we were
looking at these performances
and putting these things together there
was
always authenticity there was always
connection with the characters
and i've worked on enough shows to know
that that is not always the case
so it really helps we can be as
technologically proficient
as as anybody with this stuff
but if we don't have people on camera
who are maintaining
a consistent sense of authenticity
it's it's it's it all goes away
and so um i think
there can never be enough credit leveled
at the the cast for this show
when you guys were doing the finale of
season three
did you know when you were filming it
that the series was
not gonna come back or were you still at
the time optimistic we could get another
season
as i understand it brian we basically
finished every season on the assumption
that this would have to be a good ending
for the show
and and and that that each time works
pretty
successfully like that i don't think
there was a
was there more of a sense of the of the
sword hanging over our heads after the
third season particularly
not not not any more than any other
season and like every every time they
called and said they wanted more it was
it was a gift um and like oh uh
so it
it's interesting because usually about
halfway through whatever season we are
the the following season snaps into
focus in my head
like all of a sudden i go like oh i like
i see i see how this is going to
uh cascade into a new narrative
and the same thing happened with season
three
and i shared with you like where i
thought it was going to go
and uh what we could be doing and how it
would be
an interesting recontextualization
of relationships that that continued the
trajectory of strangeness from
from season three uh so it really
my my i guess my imagination
kind of protects me from certain
stressors
because i i know if we're if we do get
it
i've i can kind of see where we're going
and if we don't get it
then um i don't have to swim across the
wild river
again and you know because the first
season of the show was really really
troubling and i was like oh my god i
don't know if i can do this again
and then i went after going through it
and then going through it with allies
and supporters uh you know chief amongst
them being the cast
then you think like oh i can do this i
can like i can do this again because i
survived it the first time
and so that was really the attitude was
if we do it we'll do it and we'll
survive it and it'll be great because
we've got a fantastic team
and we are all capable of doing great
one
you could have ended season three i
don't want to be specific for people
that have not actually
might be watching you have not seen it
um how did you decide you wanted that
scene with the three chairs to be
um where that finale ended
was that always you know where how did
that get figured out was it ever going
to be something else
i it was it was something that came sort
of relatively late in the process
uh because it was it was
i guess in some way even for
for the character in that scene it was a
refusal to submit
you know it was like okay yes they
they've gone over the cliff
and for all intents and purposes they're
dead
but you know moriarty
etc going over cliffs is a
something that we've seen in literature
before and all those characters pop up
again
um so it for me it was
a fun wink um that
not everybody gets away and yes we saw
other
we saw the murder wives get away and
their help billionaire helicopter
um but not all the characters are going
to be so lucky
but that's not to say that that
character uh
that was the end of that character in
that scene hugh you had to do
there were some fight scenes while the
making of the series
obviously you're trying to do this on a
very tight schedule
um can you sort of talk about the
challenges of doing this kind of stuff
and
i've spoken to a number of actors and
and filmmakers and they talk about
sometimes they try to schedule the fight
scene at the end of that particular
week's
shoot to allow the actor to have more
time to learn
moves was that ever the case on hannibal
or were you sort of like
could be the first day let's just film
it
but yeah obviously you don't want to
kind of improv your way through it i
don't
i don't recall whether it was whether
they would have been scheduled at the
end of the week
or whatever it would be but but that's
exactly right i mean you have to have
time to
to practice it and and um and then you
just have to have enough time to shoot
it because however
much you've learned it you know you have
to do it several times for it to look
right
you know i mean any any fight scene um
a lot of cuts you know it's very kind of
it's very specific their hand has to
move
exactly behind the head in the right
moment um
and there wasn't a lot of time i mean
that first season
in particular i feel like i was
pretty much constantly busy
either i mean i was in you know a good a
good
majority of the of the show so um yeah
it was just another thing to add to the
schedule but i never had i never had one
of those um
like extensive extensive fight scenes so
you know like the one between men's and
lawrence another unsung hero of this
series is the music
um it adds so much like that's a whole
other character
can both of you talk about what you felt
about the music and how it added to the
show
i mean it was incredible i think he was
literally inventing instruments right in
in his in his garage yeah but brian
would
know much more about that well you know
i would be curious to hear like what
your first reaction is when
i love soundtracks and i've got like
you know stacks of them on vinyl in my
office
so i'm a big soundtrack listener and it
it it makes all the difference to to a
picture
what was your first reaction when you
heard the music you
i think it it felt like somebody had
created i mean as much as music just a
series of sounds that reflected that you
know we were you were asking earlier
about
um what we felt lucky to have gotten
away with and for all that we were
joking and laughing about blood
i was the thing that really felt um
outrageous and and
that it was going to be hard to
recapture you know after doing it for
one season was
to go so far inside somebody's breakdown
and the and and the the specific way
that their imagination is taken over and
warped and brought to life
that felt so unlikely and every
episode that arrived you know brian
would have pushed it further in very
specific visual ways
and i my feeling was basically i can't
believe i get to do this and i can't
believe i get to be part of it
so when i first heard the soundtrack it
was like
jesus christ somebody's managed to
reflect that
in sound you know and and with with a
kind of equal level
of of imagination and creativity about
how to do it it's obviously not just
you know what's the right tune he was he
really was i think
and again this is what i don't know
enough about but
i think he he was imagining certain
sounds and then figuring out how to make
them
right that's the impression i get for me
what i loved
about what brian was doing brian reitzel
uh is that we we we didn't talk
traditionally in terms of melody like
for instance on other shows that i've
done
i i i had a much more traditional
approach to the music there would be you
know uh character themes
and you know i'm pushing daisies ned had
a theme
olive had a theme chuck had a theme
emerson had an every character had an
individual theme
and an instrument assigned to them
that was you know indicative of that
theme
and then there would be extrapolations
from that and it was
it was not less complicated
but it was more traditional and so when
we were talking with brian about what
the score is it really wasn't about
melodies or themes it was about
psychological soundscapes
and what what are the sounds that you
would hear in your head
when if this were happening to you and
like what what are the sounds of
your brain bending and breaking and
warping
and what are those sounds and then you
go into brian reichel's office
and he is bending and breaking
instruments to
create new sounds that we haven't heard
before so
it really was a completely different
expression
of music and on hannibal i
i really wasn't terribly
um involved is not the wrong word but i
wasn't
meddlesome with the music in a way that
i usually am
because i'm like oh it should sound like
john williams from the 1942 soundtrack
and
like i can geek out but with this i was
like you're doing something
that i do that you're going to teach me
how to understand so i'm just going to
be an audience member and say thank you
so i was always surprised on the sound
stage because it was the first time that
i had ever heard the music
and i'd never gotten to the point where
i trusted somebody so implicitly
with such a great task that i knew that
i was
i that i wasn't perhaps qualified to
give them notes
yeah i i think the music is phenomenal
on the series
just a plus um one of the things about
season one
is that it feels like a case of the week
a lot of the times
and while season and then you progress
to season three and it's
almost like a dark hbo series you know
um
what can you sort of talk about that
progression did you always
you know the beginning of being case of
the week at the you know the first
season and now the show
morphed um obviously it's serialized but
you know what i mean how the show
changed
yes did you like the change i mean i
would assume
that the procedural stuff most actors
that i talk to
sort of are allergic to procedurals
because it's not
necessarily a character motivated
storyline so it's yeah
i i felt like i think it would have
become challenging if we had stuck with
that
as the primary model which obviously it
didn't i mean it was there as
you just said but it but it can fade a
bit more into the background
for that first season the the for me
the the arc of what was happening with
will and between will and hannibal was
so strong
and and brian's kind of weaving of that
into a more traditional
procedural model was so kind of
intricately done
that it was hard work but it was like an
interesting challenge
to think okay well how am i going to
take wherever
you know he is right now in in this in
this breakdown
um and kind of weave it into um
you know this particular absurd crime um
and and it was you know and and how many
ways i mean that
we'd sh we shoot all these scenes you
know with autopsies or whatever
and then there'd always come a moment
when the camera would like stick right
in my face and
you know it would just be kind of a
wills going crazy shot
or how is this playing out in his head
you know and and
you know you have to find different ways
to try and do that to
self-interested but just for it to
continue to be interesting
and i did find it interesting i learned
a lot about
cameras um and the different ways that
david and the other directors used their
camera to
you know to try and reflect what was
going on inside particularly will's head
and other characters but like i say
you know the kind of i learned in the
first season i remember brian telling me
the end of this season you're going to
vomit up an ear
right he didn't know whose ear it was
going to be necessarily i think that's
right but but he
certainly he had that and that to me
i don't know why it completely anchored
me in some sense of where we were going
is it your caribournette like
association
it was what it was it was like
how does it how does a person get to
that place but basically
um and i mean
and and i really liked the idea i don't
know what that says
about us but i thought great
and we were often you know things were
coming in very last minute brian was
working 24
7 rewriting things reimagining things it
was a
hectic show to make you know um and i
learned that if if i could get
that kind of anchor and i asked him the
same question ask you the same question
bro i think for each of the following
two seasons like
where are we going second season that
finale
was not of course of course written or
fully imagined but
hannibal's you know going to disembowel
you basically
so and i had that and i don't know where
how i got to this exactly but but it was
that sense of creating a shape for
myself emotional shape for it
um meant that the other stuff was was
just was
was part of gravy
yes it was gravy for the ear that's
right how many scripts did you typically
have done
before you started filming a season and
uh uh hugh how much did you want to know
like obviously you knew the finale or
you knew where it was going but
how much do you want to know about the
full arc of a character
how much are you would you rather have
it script by script
the truth is we we never had it more
than like you know each script at a time
i mean and or there would be i would
read a version of it but i learned
pretty quickly that until that version
had gone through
brian's filter um there was only so much
that it was worth my
my investing in it um beyond the kind of
general shape of where we were going
because the
specificity of the of the words and the
imagery and the dialogue was such that
um you know it was
it was not unhelpful but it wasn't
necessarily that helpful either for me
to to become invested in it
um and that worked well
i i mean whether it's the ideal i don't
know
but it did work well but because i just
had
kind of like total total trust in brian
in in in what he was doing and i knew
that he was
like i knew that he was sweating blood
honestly like and putting everything
of himself into the show and and it made
me want to do the same thing which i did
already and i knew that we had that
and and mads and all of us had that kind
of like we are in this
together and we all want to make the
best possible version of this show that
we can that we collectively imagine
and we're on the same page so that's
just that felt like this is the way it's
going to be
you know we're going like brian's off in
his little he's kind of airy
in the in the apartment in toronto where
he was hold up but
you know working all night long and
and and if that's what he needs to do to
get this to be the very best thing
it can be i'll take that like any day of
the week
for season one how many scripts did you
have done before
filming began how was it on season two
and three
how much were you you know figuring out
um one-liners if you will for each
episode or you know talk a little bit
about
how you figured out the season well i
think you know for the first season
it was it was interesting because we you
know i wrote the pilot
um and there was
a you know it was it was so
uh closely tuned to what thomas harris
uh had written and there was so much
from the books that was going into it
and uh then we had
written i think we had four or five
scripts and then i
saw the pilot and i saw the work
that that hugh and maz were doing and i
saw the work that david slade was doing
and i looked at those four or five
scripts that we had written and i said
that they weren't good enough and i
threw them out
and then we started over but we started
over
in a sense that was you know we i think
we shut down for two weeks between the
pilot and the rest of the
show so after seeing the pilot
and going like what like this is
actually really good and this
cast is phenomenal and they deserve
better material
um because the the four or five scripts
that we had
we had done were very procedural were
very and very sort of strange like one
of the episodes was about a mass
shooting in a mcdonald's
and we were trying to make this
commentary on fast food culture
and gun culture and you know
now looking back on that i'm like what
the [ __ ] were we thinking
because there's no way to skin that and
not be
offensive to somebody um not that i'm
care about offending people uh but the
it just was sort of inelegant and cheap
and not necessarily
elevating the genre and i think you know
i feel a deep responsibility to try to
elevate the
genre of whatever i'm doing um so we
tossed all those scripts out and then it
was a scramble for the rest of the
season and it was really hard on mavs
because english is his second language
and a lot of the [ __ ] that hannibal is
saying are words that i have to look up
to go like is that right like is that a
word
and so i it was it was really difficult
for him
um but we kind of like the first season
was re
was was insane and it was very
depressing and
it felt very much like uh i was in will
graham's head a little too far
uh and i remember there like there was
one time when
um hugh and claire and i were walking
around
a park and it was just like it was just
nice to be
with people who weren't
expecting something from me that i knew
i couldn't give them
and to just have general support and go
like oh like these like i said like
when when you and i had our first dinner
i was like oh
this this is going to be my friend like
this isn't just a working relationship
this is somebody that who's company that
i adore
so like those moments kind of got me
through
the complexities and the real
hardships of season one and then after
surviving something you go like oh i can
survive
but season two we got a late pickup
and so our first day in the writers room
without
anything being sort of written or
anything
we were in production six weeks later
and
so there like there was no catching up
and season two i don't know
hugh if you think season two was worse
than season one in terms of script
delivery
it's hard to say they're so
i mean yeah it's it's it's kind of
really skinning something
but it was it was it was tough all along
and and
yeah that's all i know i mean in that
respect but you know i did
i i worked after hannibal i worked on a
show and in the first step
season we had all six
six episodes they've ridden of 10 i
think we did up front they just had you
know that much time and they had they'd
scripted those six episodes and it was
great i mean it was completely
wild it was almost like a hallucination
for me
um and you know it meant it afforded me
the opportunity to
i guess you know sit with it for longer
obviously
but truthfully in the in the kind of
chaos that that
we experienced and that brian was kind
of in the front line of
uh in retrospect it didn't
kind of compromise for me the the kind
of ability to
i don't know to to kind of submerge
ourselves in it um and i
honestly don't know why that should be
except for the fact that
as i said before and as it's obvious
from what brian's saying like he he
he and we all felt that
responsibility right not just not even
to anybody else just to ourselves
right who who wants to do an artist
that's that's that's right you know
um and and i know i remember actually at
that
that kind of this dinner date which
we've now referenced several times with
brian and i
had you know uh sat and had a couple of
cocktails but i remember him saying to
me then
remember you you saying he did like six
or seven
um you know he's basically you kind of
made it almost like a formal
pledge uh just in the process of
conversation
to to kind of do something
good for us and with us and and and
subsequently i realized that that he
really he really really meant that
and it was incredibly incredibly
reassuring actually because
um you know when you're when you're
i guess right in the middle of something
and you're
you you really want it to be as good as
it can be it's
it's so nice to know that the other
person the person actually i didn't see
brian that much of course during
during the process of filming mostly
because he was just had so much writing
to do you know you're not in the same
space
um but but i just i mean i'm repeating
myself but i just knew that he
had our backs right and that um
and if something wasn't up to snuff then
it was it wouldn't
wouldn't come through or and you know if
we had thoughts that he would still
find the time to take it on and and and
it would
emerge so in some shape or other in the
in the in the script
one thing that i found really
fascinating about
people's understandings like on an
executive
level or you know perhaps not and in the
trenches level
in terms of perception of actors you
know i've worked with
with a few actors that people have said
like oh my god they're a monster
and you're gonna have a night it's gonna
be a nightmare like mandy patinkin
everybody was like he's gonna be a
nightmare
and he wasn't he was amazing he was
lovely
and what i think people don't understand
is that there is
a great
contribution that actors make by
giving you their face and their soul and
they're worried about looking like
[ __ ] if
things don't work or that
they want they they want to look good
they want to give a good performance
and when i say look good i mean like
give by
by performance not simply you know
beauty makeup
and uh so many actors that i have been
warned about were never a problem
because
they they i guess they felt that someone
was
as worried about them looking like an
[ __ ]
as they were and that helps take a lot
of pressure off if you're if you're sort
of doing something and you go like
that guy doesn't really care if i don't
do a great take
or if it's not going to be an authentic
performance they just want to make their
day and get through it
but if you're working with people who
care as much as you do and i'm saying
this
from the actors toward creatives and cr
or you know behind the scenes and behind
the scenes support actors
if everybody realizes that everybody
cares a lot
it's a great stress reducer because
you're like
part of the things that we worry about
as human beings moving through life
are the [ __ ] who don't care and
don't wear their [ __ ] masks
you know those are the things that that
make us insecure but if you're in an
environment
where like i knew sitting across from
hugh that he cared as much about this as
i did and it wasn't just a job and he
doesn't do things that are just
jobs he do he because he's an artist and
i think there were so many artists at
work on hannibal
that we all kind of vibrated at that
frequency and
and it is a dramatic stress reducer as a
viewer
of a lot of movies and television and
a lot of stuff i i can usually see when
it
when there's you can usually it shines
through when everyone is
really giving a [ __ ] about what they're
putting on screen and
trying their hardest um sure
i could go on and on about that but my
next question what was the toughest
stuff
to write and what was the toughest stuff
to perform
you know i think this like really for me
that
the everything was sort of like weird
and challenging in terms of the writing
um the because it was
this mashup it was it was uh
you know it wasn't kind of a like oh
we're trying to be as real as possible
and we're trying to tell an authentic
story
we were trying to do something a little
weird and we were trying to do something
a little out of the ordinary so there
isn't necessarily
an accurate barometer that we can trust
and lean on so
i found often like i like i will cry
when i'm writing a scene like
if i'm if a character's crying i will
often cry because i'm trying to be in
that headspace
so you can imagine like being in will
graham's headspace uh
particularly that first season was
really challenging
because it i was i i felt like i
understood him i
felt like i was associating with him
perhaps too much in certain cases
because i would be
you know so in his head in a way
that um
it was hard for me to to disassociate
his pain as an amplifier for things that
i might have been feeling with
frustrations in the production or
or feeling the lack of support or those
things it was very easy for me to
identify
with with with will in that regard
and so it's hard to pick out like
what was what was hard because it
it it was all hard um
if that makes sense it does it's funny i
mean i i feel the
same way in a sense that
you know and maybe this is this is
broadly true
not just of this show but but but there
were a lot of moments like this that
that
clearly when you read them in advance
like that's going to be quite a hill to
climb i mean
obviously the scene at the end of the
second season
for example but i mean i could pick any
any number just emotionally you know to
to
go through that i know i don't mean like
oh woe is me i'll have to go through it
i mean
to do it and that's kind of rise up to
it and with the appropriate emotion
that's
that's going to be hard to get there or
i mean or the scene when when will when
my wife you know nina nina ariendo when
she wakes up in the hospital i mean you
know that was up but
but actually all of those
i don't ever remember i mean you always
walk away wondering you know how did i
do or how was that but but i don't
remember ever walking away from those
thinking we didn't
get to the place that we needed to get
to um it was as
you know that was the joy of the show
right that you got we were asked to do
do those things um amidst this kind of
crazy
cooking show right there was there was
serious emotional gymnastics going on
and um so so if anything
right it was almost like that and then
interspersed with
with you know going back to the kind of
procedural stuff so it was
trying to kind of stay in the same the
same headspace with this kind of
radically different moments i suppose
was
the challenge but again kind of a good
one right because
you have to be quite limber and quite
quite fast on your feet it felt like
that anyway
um i want to just go back to brian
walking in the park with claire and me
in that first season because i
remembered oh yeah that's right and then
i remembered
and then we had to go away for the
weekend and we we had our dog there and
brian brian didn't have his dogs with
him because they were back in l.a right
so
we thought well two birds with one stone
maybe brian would like or
wouldn't mind babe dog sitting a dog and
he so kindly did and then when we were
away he
he kindly sent me photos of himself
putting the dog into the oven
hotdog
you know you do what you can
um bit of a fun question uh who ruined
the most
takes and why
ah i mean i don't get to watch all the
takes
um i mean you know scott and
aaron i was gonna say
you know i mean because they were they
were asked to do particular stuff and
scott i mean scott can can break you
know
pretty well and cause others to break oh
yeah pretty well
um so yeah i'm nominating them
i i would agree like i think they're
they're
scott was definitely an instigator
uh for breaking uh because he would say
something very subtle
and he would know exactly what he was
doing and he would just like let it
linger
until the sparks started flying but i
will say the hardest
the hardest scene to get through which
in fact i don't think we ever did get
through was
for me was from was me and lawrence
standing over raul after he had been to
chris and he had been through
as he's not not shy of mentioning like
six hours of makeup
and you know his face is hanging off him
and you you will see
this and it was just hysterical
and he was doing all these sort of like
fireman bill
kind of impressions with the the the
teeth that were actually outside of his
lips
uh those dailies were hilarious
um i believe you guys tried to get david
bowie
uh for the series yeah can you sort of
share
like the behind the scenes of what you
wanted him to do
um how close did it come the david bowie
thing was really about
honestly who's going to be as cool
as maz mickelson and
uh they're
and it's also like he's
an exemplary artist and god wouldn't it
be
amazing to just be able to
uh be in the presence of that level of
um confident self-expression
and so we we inquired um
and he said thank you very much i'm i'm
working on a new album
uh but try again and
what we didn't realize at the time was
every time we would ask and he would say
thank you very much i'm working on an
album
that he was actually very sick and so
uh that was you know one of those things
that like
that just never came to pass but would
have been
amazing amazing to be able to to work
with him in any capacity
did you know when you reached out to him
what you wanted him
to do on the series yes he was going to
play
uh hannibal lecter's uncle and
uh who was aware of some of the family
secrets
so we gave a lot of that story to tawa
komodo
and chio in season three um
some of the things just the the the
person from hannibal's past
who knows him better and from a
different perspective than any of the
characters in his
his present-day life so um a lot of
a lot of the kind of emotional aspects
of that story
we wove into chio's story
in season three if he had said i can do
one episode
or two episodes max would that have been
a deal breaker
or no i'm sorry david
you're in no because you obviously want
him to disperse information
and backstory and add to the character
you know
we need you for backstory david
it's not a good way to like convince the
kid
that's why i'm not on that side of the
camera um
i would have taken whatever time
that he had available michael pitt was
obviously a part of the series
did not return for the third season um
was
i don't maybe it's public knowledge
maybe it's not what can you share what
happened was it just
he didn't want to come back was it he
had a different scheduling issue
well we did we definitely wanted him
back he was fantastic on the second
season
and there were like we weren't able to
close the deal
and uh and that's kind of the
the the simple uh the simplicity of it
we weren't we weren't able to close the
deal
and um and
but i i feel like we we did okay
joe was amazing a hundred percent
um i'm going to read a question that
someone sent me because i want to make
sure it's uh i want to give someone from
twitter
a little uh you know uh hannibal is
infinitely rewatchable i find new things
every time for example
will hiding his injured hand from freddy
when he visits her after
beating randall tear what are some
details you added that you hoped people
would appreciate
oh god i i
i this is when i find i mean repeatedly
realize that there are a lot of people
out there at this point who know this
show so much better than me
and and and i just wanted to kind of not
let them down
basically because you know i
i i mean i personally um
i find that i'm i'm i'm being reminded
at the stage of of individual lines and
individual moments that that i
i when reminded i fondly remember but
but have
no longer you know they're not at the
forefront of my mind anymore
it's it's interesting because i feel
like everything is kind of packed with
as many nuances
as we can possibly squeeze in there and
it's not just like
me squeezing them in there it's the art
department squeezing them in there it's
the directors
the actors it's you know so
there's there's so i'm trying to think
of like a
a particularly
juicy detail um
but i they all kind of have equal
importance to me so so one doesn't stand
out
you know there's there are horror movie
homages throughout and there are homages
through
you know through lots of uh
different aspects and even lines of
dialogue that are
are given um a different weight because
it's a reference to something else but
i can't think of anything that anybody
hasn't
got and every once in a while like i'll
see a tweet and they're like did you
mean this and i was like oh yeah like
that was yeah of course
like that's what it was supposed to be
um
but it yeah one doesn't leap out i'm
sorry a lot is happening in such a short
period of time
and obviously editing can make and
inform what the episode is finally going
to be
so i think for for the actors on the
series you know
while you're on set you don't
necessarily know what it's all going to
be until the finished episode exists
because of the
editing choices that can be done
yeah yeah and you don't you don't
necessarily have a full sense of what
the
what the director is and you have a
vague sense of what the director's doing
with the camera but
if there's something quite specific and
subtle as there often was and
particularly with
with david for example um likewise with
all the
you know the second unit stuff so no you
don't i remember
watching i think brian you screamed
maybe the first two
episodes for us some way into the first
season
and it was really kind of eye-opening oh
that's
i mean i guess the same experience that
you had too brian after you watched the
first one
that's what that's what we're doing and
also realizing how much work brian had
done in the edit
after the fact to further kind of mesh
the two episodes together to make sure
to make sure that that that through
story was
was at the forefront you know he it was
as on on the page versus what what he
managed to do with some tweaks i think
uh it felt more episodic initially so i
was delighted to see
how how you had kind of um
you know you created something that was
going to be more of an arc
um uh what did each of you take home
from set
literally yeah what what do you have in
your apartment if you will
god that's it i don't what do i have i
mean will the problem is that will
didn't really have anything
there was nothing to take um i mean i i
think i've got
i've got a lot you know i have a lot
more of things that um
people and fanables have given me
subsequently right i have
and brian you know is the same a sizable
collection
indeed brian has subsequently sent me
things um
that that he's received maybe to be
given to me or just that he felt that i
would particularly appreciate
i remember kind of a pair of bloodied
hands that arrived
not long ago many many many i've got i
mean it's an awful thing to say but both
of my sons have grown up with
little kind of stuffed dolls of me kind
of bloodied and bearded
like in their cribs you know and when
when they goes and and you name it
i got some cool props i've got like i've
got
will's crazy mask back there and i've
got hannibal's crazy mask
back there i've got mason berger's crazy
mask
um and there's
i've got uh eddie izzard is in my garage
wrapped in plastic like his like his
corpse is
uh limbless corpse uh
which i pull out for halloween parties
and
um it's surprisingly
lifelike to the touch um
i've got i've got a lot i've got a lot
of crazy [ __ ] but
i i think some of my most cherished
things are
from fandibles whether it's it's
handmade stuffed items i've got
literally
dozens of flower crowns that i've
collected
basically i have everything
that anybody has ever given me like any
letter
i have and i have them in a box and
garage
and when i'm sometime between scripts i
i absolutely do intend to
to to read those and because somebody
took the time to write them
and that doesn't that is not wasted on
me
so i think even though i have like
really cool props from the show i think
some of the
the most cherished stuff are are things
that
that the fanables have given me and
it's just it's wonderful because i think
we
we often forget about the medicinal
quality of entertainment
and i think for some for a show like
hannibal that's so weird
and takes a unique perspective to to
appreciate
we're going to find like-minded folks
who
are coming to entertainment as a as a
solve
i certainly know growing up in a really
uh violent home
that when i was escaping to
star wars or star trek that it was
medicinal
and that it was it was a safe spot that
that was rarely afforded to me in those
times so i think
when we are interacting with fannibles
of which i count myself one because i i
love thomas harris and his writing and
the characters
that that we often forget that
reality is really hard even on the best
of days
and so when we're able to escape into a
fantasy
it it feels wonderful and i think when
people
if they give me a letter detailing that
or
make a stuffed animal or windigo
or a flower crown that feels
like there feels like for me a cycle of
mental health um because we
we seek out the things that that make us
feel safe and
entertainment often makes us feel safe
and as crazy as it sounds
this show makes a lot of people feel
safe
and safe in their weirdness
and as animals said it's fine to be
weird so um
yeah i had obviously heard about
fannibles and
and the passion for the series i often
put on twitter before i'm going to talk
to people hey
you have any questions send them my way
um there was a lot let's just say that
the level of interest in sending me
stuff for this particular interview
um was uh on the uh extreme side
yay i'll say it like i'll say not in a
bad way i love
passionate fans i'm a passionate fan and
the thing that i think a lot of people
forget and i'm
sorry for inserting myself is that you
know sometimes i
sometimes people send in really good
questions you know or
or mention things you don't even think
to ask about and that's why i try to
involve fans and
in all the interviews i do because they
sometimes come up with really good
things
you know they're like we're smart
like you know the fan community like
we're
we're smart people who enjoy thinking
about things and talking about things
and having a discourse
so that's why you know the comic cons
and
and those sorts of gatherings are really
important and
feel magical
in a way because if you're growing up in
a home where you don't feel understood
if you're
if you're in a social situation where
you don't feel understood
it's nice to go to places and be around
people
who have the same level of
misunderstandings in their lives and
that's a bonding
uh currency to to exchange so it's
it's i'm glad that you're you're you're
facilitating these interviews because i
do i do think
that um you know
entertainment has many many purposes and
every once in a while like
writing now during the pandemic and
everything that's happening with black
lives matter it's very easy to go
like oh my god this is so cool and then
immediately to like
nothing [ __ ] matters because the
world is on fire
and i have to keep reminding myself that
maybe something that we're doing can
help extinguish somebody else's fire
in an unexpected way down the road
because they will feel
seen by whatever we're trying to
communicate
by being artists and it doesn't
necessarily mean
we're we're promoting cannibalism
although i would i would promote that
more than eating
most animals um but it's just
it's just really about acknowledging
that we're all here there's a lot of
stories
it's a very complex thing to be alive
and to have a brain
and to have so many choices running
through that brain at any given time
that
it's impossible to make the right ones
every time
so we like storytelling and artistry is
just another
embrace of the the human condition a
thousand percent
um last thing uh uh you do you think
that you are on
too many social media channels
do you mean or me personally i'm joking
around about not being on any social
channel
that you're aware of right
i mean it's not like i don't live in a
bunker you know i
i do i do have some access to the
outside world but
it is true it's it's a little limited
compared to mads though i'm practically
living in the future i think
uh last thing for you guys um obviously
at some point
filming is gonna begin uh hugh do you
know what you're gonna be doing down the
road
i have no idea i was gonna be doing a
play on broadway that was gonna start
rehearsing in november that's now
rescheduled for somewhere between fall
of 2021 and 2022
so i mean you know it's it's and who
knows what that means that just really
means
sometime in the future right we hope um
so no i have no no real sense of it
got it and uh brian what are you working
on i
i've been working in features for
the last year i'm on my my third feature
and i wrote an original
for myself to direct and i just sold
that before
everything went crazy um
and then i've been working on two sort
of uh bigger ip
films and like none of which are
like i'm supposed to be talking about so
i'm doing nothing
exactly um you'd be surprised how many
people i speak to that um
are working on ips that they can't talk
about yeah it's interest
it's fascinating like one of my
executives
like because we've we've been so uh
diligently secretive
about uh the project
but he's always telling me how he's
pitching it to everybody and i'm like
like i haven't even told my mom um thank
you guys so much
good to see you steve great to see you
you like
i i we need to be in person sometime
soon yeah wouldn't that be nice